Hey youtubers it's Charlie and this week's
Teen Wolf taught us a whole new way to make
a new werewolf.
Raise your hand if it made you hungry.
Don't worry I won't judge.
There's actually a whole bunch of stuff to
talk about.
There were at least 4 major new plot lines
that started so let's just chomp right in.
Hello new people, if you're finding me for
the first time I do weekly Teen Wolf videos.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
I just made a new playlist in the description
so check there to travel down the youtube
teen wolf rabbit hole.
I'm going
to start with my top 5 moments and then do
my review.
Careful for spoilers from Episode 3 if you
haven't seen it yet.
I'll wait just a sec...Okay, Number 5 - Kate
Took Derek's True Nature
We finally got an answer to his eye color.
I actually thought it was some conceit of
the de-aging spell.
But it sounds like Kate did that too him both
to get inside the vault and to take his true
nature.
The only reason that comes to mind is that
she needs it to power some other weird ritual.
When they said 'True Nature' it made me think
of identity, like Kate took who Derek was,
so Derek won't be able to do something really
important later this season until he gets
it back.
Did you see the way he was acting too.
I actually thought it was young Derek in old
Derek's body.
He seemed like he was staring at himself a
lot, like he didn't know himself.
I have to give props to Tyler Hoechlin for
being able to do a different version of Derek
without it seeming cheesy.
Let me know what you think we should call
this Derek, like we can call regular Derek,
Derek Prime and this Derek, Shadow Derek.
It does seem like he's just a fraction of
himself right now.
Like he's in panic mode.
Number 4 - Lydia Finds The Meat Locker
If you were confused, don't feel bad.
It took me till that end reveal of Sean as
a Wendigo.
The mute, played by Joseph Gatt from Game
of Thrones was killing his family because
they were supernatural.
It seemed like he did something funky to him
in that bathroom, but really the mute is attacking
supernatural families in Beacon Hills.
It's part of the deadpool kill list and the
benefactor.
The next episode, episode 4 is called "The
Benefactor" so presumably we'll find out who
that is, but when Lydia found all those bodies
in the secret room.
She was finding Sean's families' meat fridge.
Wendigos are from Algonquin mythology.
They were basically cannibal monsters.
So that's why those were human bodies.
The family just kept them on ice like you'd
keep steaks on ice.
Pretty gross huh, that's why at the end when
he said, "I'm so hungry" he wasn't on drugs
or anything.
He just hadn't fed on human flesh in a long
time.
Don't ask what he kept in his gatorade bottle.
The other important thing of note here is
Lydia forming a connection with Deputy Parrish.
He seemed amazingly sanguine about her supernatural
banshee status even though I don't think he
knows she's a banshee.
She still doesn't understand how her power
works, so they just treat it like a weird
WTF skill she has.
I think this is going to turn into more of
a mulder scully relationship where she starts
being more proactive about getting to crime
scenes.
Her power draws her to people who are near
death or who have just died.
So she's got a super radar for death.
I'm really excited to see her get better at
using it.
Number 4 - Malia versus Math
I love the way the show bounces between adorable
and crazy murder so fast.
Last week I said Malia was my favorite character
so far this year.
I think Lacrosse Kira might give her a run
for her money but the look on her face when
she walked into math class was priceless.
I feel like the reaction faces some of the
characters have is what they're really paid
for.
It's a rare art to be able to make faces like
this on command all day.
It was like there was a giant middle finger
drawn on the chalk board.
It's just a twist on the challenges the characters
face.
Like Malia is more afraid of Math than she
is of Berserkers squishing them like grapes.
So her ultimate triumph this year will be
slaying Calculus, not the Benefactor.
But the cool part is that brainiac Stiles
gets to be her wingman.
Out on the battlefield he can't do that, he's
like a squishy cloth-wearing mage and she's
a plate wearing warrior.
Except he doesn't have any magic, unless you
consider doing homework magic.
Speaking of which Lydia's crazy notes.
Those were the same symbols on the computer
screen of the mute.
Which seem like encoded instructions from
the benefactor.
I didn't recognize them, but if you think
you know what they are just write it in the
comments.
Number 3 - The Mute Is Killing Peoples
So here's a weird thought.
If he has no mouth, how did he speak to Sean
at the beginning of the episode when he trapped
him in the bathroom?
Or was that voice coming from the benefactor
and not the mute?
We'll probably have to wait to find out as
we haven't seen the mute communicate with
anyone directly, beyond making the whisper
motion to Scott.
He's pretty clearly getting instructions from
the benefactor via that weird computer pipeline
he plugged into.
It's like some kind of magical cyber gear.
Like a combination of technology and magic.
There was actually a Marvel "What If" storyline
where Tony Stark became Doctor Strange and
inscribed all these magical runes on his Iron
Man suit so that he could automate spells.
I don't think we'll see anything like that
on Teen Wolf, but I really want to find out
how the benefactor is using the internet to
program the mute.
He seems like he has cognition and free will.
But he also kind of seems like a flesh and
blood robot being controlled with a magical
remote.
Number 2 - Kira Joins the Lacrosse Team
Even though lacrosse felt like the challenge
for her this week and the relationship with
Scott was the reward.
It felt like it should have been the other
way around.
Like she had to overcome Scott's derpy-ness
and as a reward she'd get to join the lacrosse
team.
Scott's the real challenge for her.
Lacrosse is too easy for her to be a challenge.
Just look at her twirl her lacrosse stick,
I could watch a gif of this for hours.
I can't wait to see her decapitate someone
with it.
The whole parent's moving plot seems like
a dead end.
Like they might just drop that, because she's
not going to leave the series and she's not
going to move in with Lydia or Malia but I
don't mind.
I am so much more excited about Lacrosse now
that it's not going to be a straight up redo
of Freshman year lacrosse.
With Kira on the team now I feel like the
Lacrosse scenes will be all about her, which
is way more fun than watching Scott go alpha
over everyone.
That's what season 1 was all about, him using
werewolf powers on the field.
So I'm glad Kira is going to make it interesting.
and my Number 1 WTF moment, of course - Scott
Bites Liam
Full disclosure, I knew this was going to
happen a long time ago.
The creator of the show, Jeff Davis was talking
about Liam becoming Scott's new beta all summer.
I just didn't know how it was going to happen.
How he was going to give him the bite.
I thought it was a really cool twist, Scott
would have never willingly bitten someone.
The real fun part was Scott's reaction after
the mute left.
There were two big moments in the episode
where Scott's Brain just went offline and
then had like a violent reboot.
The first time was when he unconsciously kissed
Kira on the way to class and then was like
wait what?!
And then the second time was the Bite, where
he was like WTF Derp?!
I'd call him Derp Scott in this episode, but
he was being a hero and I love the idea of
Scott having a Beta that's a brand new character.
So I forgive him for being a space cadet.
Here's my big question for you?
Looking back at all your favorite Scott moments
in the last couple of seasons, how many times
do you think he's been mentally out to lunch
and then did that delayed reaction face?
And do you think this is like a really big
issue with him not being able to think in
the moment?
or do you think it's just him acting on instinct
and he's not just totally spacing out during
important moments.
Overall I gave the episode a B plus, This
was my favorite episode of the season so far.
I love the Liam character so far but I feel
like we won't really get to know him until
he's part of the pack.
Lacrosse Kira wins so hard with me and Malia
and her Markers were a nice misdirect for
what's probably going to turn into a serious
problem later when she figures out Peter is
her father.
Remember Stiles looking at the people chart
on her wall.
It's too bad this airs during the summer,
because I'd love to see a Halloween episode
where they all dress up as Avengers.
You guys can pick who gets to be who, but
Scott has to be Captain America and Lydia
has to be Scarlet Witch.
Everybody else is up for grabs.
Maybe Malia could be She-Hulk or Angela.
I feel like there's this weird pattern emerging
with the characters, like they face challenges
and if they defeat them.
Like if Malia defeats Math, she gets to be
a real person.
She's like Pinnochio trying to become a normal
human and Kira is trying to fit in, so if
she can kick ass at lacrosse and defeat Scott's
reluctance she'll get a relationship and everyone's
acceptance.
Let me know what you think Lydia's and Stiles
rewards are if they can defeat their challenges.
So this week was kind of crazy with Guardians
of the Galaxy stuff going on, but I'm going
to try to do an extra Teen Wolf bonus video
next Monday.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
I've also got a playlist in the description.
Right now click here for my Episode 2 video
and click here for my episode 1 video.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!